bonsoir docteur Denis Pagès vous êtes le
responsable prélèvement pour le pôle
ouest de l'Établissement français du
sang dans la région Île-de-France demain
vendredi Journée mondiale des donneurs
10e édition de ce rendez-vous la France
qui participe depuis depuis 8 ans pas
depuis de l'origine mais depuis 8 ans à
quoi sert ce moment particulier c'est le
moment où jamais de faire passer le
message alors
c'est la journée mondiale des donneurs
en fait ce sont les donneurs qui sont à
l'honneur et pas le don du sang le but
de cette journée et de sensibiliser les
gens à l'importance vitale qu'il y a de
donner son sang puisqu'on sait que le
son artificiel notamment les globules
rouges en admettant que ça marche ça
sera pas avant 30 ans donc la journée
mondiale du don du sang ça permet nous
permettre de rappeler à l'ensemble de la
population que le don du sang lors dont
du sang est indispensable pour pouvoir
soigner et guérir les gens qui sont
malades et comme les gens vivent plus
longtemps on en traite plus souvent et
donc c'est très important pour nous et
puis ça met aussi en valeur et bien les
associations d'honneur de sang bénévoles
qui nous aident tout au long de l'année
pour réussir effectivement à collecter
les quantités de sang dans les patients
ont besoin des associations vous le
dites qui sont mobilisés vous aussi vous
serez mobilisés demain pour cette
journée à Versailles notamment notamment
à Versailles
pas loin de la mairie juste devant et où
nous avons mis un dispositif spécial
pour accueillir le maximum de donneurs
un chiffre 100000 ce serait le nombre de
dons nécessaires en France par jour
c'est bien ça est-ce qu'on en est loin
non mais on y est presque parfois on y
est mais avec certaines difficultés et
le message aussi essentiel de la Journée
mondiale des donneurs de sang c'est que
donner une fois c'est bien alors le jour
de la journée c'est bien mais le mieux
c'est de donner régulièrement tout
l'année et puis à tous les donneurs qui
donnent une fois par occasion et bien
s'il pouvait donner une deuxième
effectivement nous serions dans cette
hypothèse de pouvoir travailler en toute
sérénité parce que ça aussi c'est
important à souligner les pochettes de
globules rouges ne peuvent se conserver
que 42 jours et les plaquettes 5 jours
d'où l'importance de donner
régulièrement son son on parle de des
dons donc ce soir on va s'intéresser au
cas de l'Île-de-France peut-être un peu
plus particulièrement et c'est donc qui
sont malgré tout toujours insuffisants
qu'est-ce qui pourrait vous inciter à
donner votre sang c'est notre question
du jour micro-trottoir
pour sauver les vies quoi
les accidents de la route et tout moi
j'ai donné pendant 20 ans donc tout
simplement pour sauver des vies c'est
très simple pour aider les autres tout
simplement et je le donne de temps en
temps enfin je ne peux plus le donner
maintenant vu mon âge j'y pense pas
sinon je l'aurais facilement
par plaisir la première fois c'était le
gamin d'une copine avait un
empoisonnement du sang il a fallu
changer comme j'étais au positif c'est
pour redonner la vie aux personnes qu'on
a besoin quoi c'est donner de l'amour
donner de la joie donner de solidarité
donner de tout quoi c'est important
c'est du gros pot donc je sais que c'est
le groupe de donneurs universel donc
c'est important voilà donner son sang
les plaquettes non je l'ai pas fait vous
avez une frange sur vous non
finalement c'est juste la prise de
conscience qui manque parce que sinon ce
sera un geste assez simple malgré tout
l'établissement français du sang avait
fait une enquête fin 2012 avec
l'Institut de santé publique
d'épidémiologie et de développement de
Bordeaux avec un questionnaire qui était
rempli par quelques 8000 étudiants entre
18 et 30 ans et pour voir un petit peu
quelles étaient les freins aux dons chez
les femmes c'était la peur d'être de
faire un malaise la crainte également de
l'aiguille par contre chez les garçons
c'est tellement que de temps ce sont des
bonnes excuses ou
alors de mon expérience modeste
les femmes ont moins peur de la piqûre
que les hommes
elles ne font pas plus souvent de
malaise et d'ailleurs les les malaises
ça se rend compte souvent lors du
premier don et j'allais dire chez les
gens qui sont assez grands et minces et
les garçons participent largement à la
statistique dans les garçons ils ont
peur de la piqûre ou largement plus que
les femmes ils préfèrent on préfère dire
puisque ce sont les garçons on va
s'impliquer un peu quand même on préfère
dire qu'on manque de temps voilà oui
aussi
organisés parce que vous allez au devant
des entreprises et peut-être aussi en
profiter pour dire qu'on peut libérer du
temps sur son temps de travail pour
aller faire un don la majorité des
entreprises soit nous accueillent en
leur saint et donc nous réserve 5 à 6
heures dans une journée alors certaines
plusieurs fois par an pour permettre la
collaborateur de donner leur sang
vous organisons avec l'aide des
associations d'honneur de son bénévoles
et le soutien de nombreuses communes du
département des Yvelines des collectes
le soir pour que les gens rentrent du
travail puissent donner et puis pour
sensibiliser les jeunes nous allons
aussi dans les milieux scolaires et
universitaires parce que on a besoin de
sensibiliser et en quelque sorte de les
initiés à la nécessité du nom de sang et
si on veut s'absenter lorsqu'on
travaille pour aller donner son sang en
règle générale
l'employeur ne fait pas de de reproches
et bon le problème dans l'entreprise
vous avez des réunions etc il y a un
emploi du temps c'est sûr mais quand on
reste 5h30 6h dans une entreprise on
peut toujours trouver le temps de
journée mondiale du don du sang Journée
mondiale des donneurs ce sont les
donneurs qui sont à l'honneur de main
vendredi 190 pays participent dont la
France pourquoi le 14 juin vous le savez
le 14 juin oui parce que c'est la
découverte des groupes sanguins par un
Autrichien qui s'appelait Carlos Staner
d'où d'ailleurs le surnom de la mascotte
qui s'appelle Carl la globulle et puis
ce monsieur dans le Schneider a
découvert avec un collègue 15 ans plus
tard effectivement les groupes Rhésus
cette année c'est pour la première fois
la France est le pays haute de cette
opération des donneurs qui sont mis à
l'honneur ça change quoi
pas grand chose au niveau du don du sang
beaucoup au niveau de l'EFS puisque
c'est la reconnaissance de de la qualité
du travail que qui m'a été effectué
depuis maintenant une bonne dizaine
d'années et qui nous permet d'assumer et
d'assurer une sécurité maximum à la fois
pour les donneurs et pour les recevoir
le FS c'est 152 sites fixes de collecte
collecte pardon 40000 sites mobiles
quelle est cette des lieux on peut faire
pour le pour le département pour la
région aussi alors bah écoutez pour le
sur l'année 2012 par exemple sur grosso
modo 300 et quelques collectes nous
avons collecté plus de 26000 poches de
produits s'engage elle parle de sans
total pour avoir
accueilli plus de 30000 personnes ce qui
représente grosso modo plus de la moitié
des résultats du pôle dont j'ai la
responsabilité donc les Yvelines
compte je crois 38 associations
d'honneur de son bénévoles et un
département où la générosité et je
dirais de mise il faut donner
régulièrement vous l'avez dit on peut
peut-être aussi rappeler qui peut donner
son sang est-ce que tout le monde peut
donner son sang alors on peut donner son
sang dès lors qu'on est majeur
c'est-à-dire la majorité du temps qu'on
a 18 ans mais il faut être majeur légale
il faut avoir un poids minimum de 50 kg
et on peut donner jusqu'à l'âge de 70
ans 65 et puis après bon il y a quelques
conditions particulières faut pas venir
Agen par exemple contrairement à ce
qu'on vous demande de faire pour une
prise de sang dans un laboratoire de
biologie et puis après bah il y a
quelques contre-indications temporaires
comme un soin dentaire une carie ou un
retour de voyage où là c'est un peu plus
long tout ce tout sourds pour assurer la
sécurité du receveur les homosexuels
peuvent donner aussi non toujours pas
pour le moment
les commissions européennes qui établit
qui a mis en place un système de veille
permanente estime que
les statistiques ne vont pas en faveur à
ce jour de de l'autorisation pour les
homosexuels hommes de donner leur sang
ceci dit si la contradiction est
permanente elle n'est pas définitive et
je sais que le dossier sur le bureau de
notre ministre tutelle au Canada c'est
possible oui au Canada et en
Grande-Bretagne mais cette façon de dire
oui tout en disant non c'est à dire
qu'il ne faut pas qu'il y ait de rapport
dans l'année qui précède le don
c'est un petit peu compliqué certains je
crois que le Canada c'est même 5 ans
donc là effectivement
si on a une accident de 5 ans si on a dû
avoir une hépatite ou le SIDA on le sait
tout de suite donc non l'objectif c'est
de savoir si effectivement ces gens-là
pourront donner et c'est pas une
hypothèse qui est farfelue et qui est
forcément lointaine dans le temps comme
les personnes qui ne partagent pas les
les mêmes orientations
j'en ai des donneurs demain est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet au-delà de la journée
de demain mais plus globalement la
veille des vacances d'été sur lui parce
que il y a beaucoup de gens qui vont
donner demain et c'est fantastique mais
il faut rappeler que en fait bon il y a
une journée mondiale et on en metra bien
qui est une journée nationale tous les
jours voilà comme ça le message est
clair merci à vous et n'oubliez pas
d'aller donc donner votre sang merci
Docteur d'avance